hello fellow soldiers it's Michael
nolles here a general in the war on
Christmas we are all part of Santa's
Army actually Santa doeses have a
religious connection to the holiday
which is about the birth of our Lord
Jesus Christ and the connection being
that Sant is based on St Nicholas
there's very many interesting things to
say about Christmas and then there are a
lot of uninteresting stupid things to
say about Christmas which is what the
libs who are waging the war on Christmas
say all the time so here is our annual
edition of the Liberals latest talking
points in the war on Christmas take it
away I think I figured out why it is
that I hate Christmas music I just don't
buy it I just don't buy it it's nothing
more than a marketing toy to get you to
like buy more stuff and it's all like
about Christianity and Jesus Christ you
know I was kind of with her in the first
part I agree that a lot of Christmas
music which people just play during
Advent is just a a marketing ploy to get
you to buy more stuff it's all just
about consumerism CS Lewis wrote A good
essay on this about the difference
between Christmas and exmas you know
exmas is this new holiday where you just
celebrate material items and no one's
really happy about it I agree with that
then she goes on to saying all this
Christmas music it's just about Jesus
but it's not the problem is virtually
none of it's about Jesus Anymore
Christians Catholics a lot of people
claim claim to worship some sort of
Messiah some sort of like Guru of
supreme knowledge of Holiness and etc
etc etc this is how you can tell This
Woman's brain has just been melted by
like white liberal girl watered down
boot bu ISM she doesn't even know how to
approach the religion that she's
describing on its own terms she's using
words that come from the East and from
the non-theistic religions Jesus is a
guru of supreme knowledge no serious
person has ever referred to Jesus our
lord as a guru he's God not a guru of
supreme knowledge not some like Yogi
sitting you know with cross legs while a
sitar plays not whatever like hippie
white dude leads her Kundalini Yoga
class the God like the one God thank you
to the internet we are witnessing things
as we have never before
witnessed in humanity in the history of
humanity we're witnessing you know greed
Slaughter in the name of Holiness you
know Israel is doing it right now to the
Palestinians claiming that uh Jewish
people have the right to those lands and
to get it by any means necessary they
even floated the idea of dropping oh can
you put a pause here so this woman is
attacking Christianity because Jews and
Muslims are killing each other does that
does that make a lot of sense to you
what in as much as Christians are
involved in the war in the Middle East
it's as victims as a very very tiny
minority who have no political power
whatsoever in the state of Israel or in
the Palestinian territories you're going
to attack of course because it's
Politically Incorrect to attack Muslims
you're not allowed to do that on the
left there are slightly more inclined to
attack Jews especially on college
campuses but the group that you're
really supposed to attack all the time
is Christianity even though they have
absolutely nothing to do with the
conflict Israel has already dropped the
equivalent of two nuclear bombs on
Palestine so I hate Christmas music
because we uh I don't buy it and we our
Gods right now are money
and power yeah okay I'm now agreeing
with her Palestine as always well I
don't know about that palese will be
free it's yeah okay I don't know about
that part the commentary here is that
this woman hates Jews she she's kind of
schizophrenic here in her take because
the part right before where she says
we're just ruled by greed and power
right now those are the false gods that
are ruling us I think yeah basically
good point we're principalities and
powers and spiritual wickedness in high
places totally true but if if this woman
hates the Jews then she should attack
you know Hanukkah or something in any
case why you going after Christianity
lady why I believe cuz that happens to
be the uh right one but also even if you
don't think that it's because this woman
comes from Christendom she comes from a
civilization that was formed by
Christianity and she's resentful of that
and a lot of other things and so she's
attacking The God Who who made her
civilization great and the neglect of
whom has made our civilization fall into
Decay and false gods as she points
[Music]
out right now go to genucell.com NES YT
letter y letter T I have got a Christmas
gift idea that is sure to make you the
hero of the Season we all know the
holiday season can be a little bit
hectic the shopping the cooking the long
list of things to do if Fe not because
I've discovered a gift that is both
thoughtful and transformative the gift
of genus cell skincare from now until
Christmas Jus cell's most popular
package has a special discount just for
our listeners at jus.com letter y letter
T treat yourself and your loved ones to
the absolute best skincare in the world
those troubling forehead wrinkles fine
line skin redness sagging jawline will
disappear right before your eyes with
jus cell's most popular collection Jus
Cel promise promises immediate effects
you will see results in less than 12
hours guaranteed or your money back
their products use the best stuff out
there on the market the prices are
incredibly competitive and in fact they
will give you special holiday discounts
because they know even if they lose
money on this order they know that you
are going to keep coming back that is
how good it is go to Jus cell.com
nsyt get this incredible holiday
discount today every order is instantly
upgraded to free express shipping j.com
nsyt
[Music]
[Applause]
today still going on about those people
I guess it's not really a talking point
about Christmas it's that this woman
wants Palestine to be free and here uh
she has a representation of the Madonna
of of our Lady and the baby Jesus and
our lady is wearing a Palestinian kefia
which seems pretty sacriligious it is
simply an incontrovertible historical
fact that our lady and our Lord are Jews
sometimes they'll say you know Jesus is
from Palestine which is I guess sort of
true and then the pro-israel people will
say well Palestine is just a madeup
thing which is I guess that's true but
all states are kind of made up things
and that area had been called Palestine
since what 70 ad it was called Palestine
by the Romans in 136 CE but there was
also the Kingdom of Israel there was
Judea there was before that there were
the Philistines and so these things go
back a long ways but trying to
appropriate our Lord and Lady for the
cause of Hamas verus the modern nation
state of Palestine or Israel for that
matter doesn't it's not great well the
more you know uh Jingle Bells was not
originally a Christmas song and it was
first performed in a menstrual show the
composer of the song is known for other
songs that were performed in menstruals
campon races
D was made to mock the way that can you
speak up please Dem cat horn quite
literally about a
slave there's a lot of racism in the
roots of the United
States and it definitely needs to be
acknowledged
run all night run all day got my money
on the
bag bet on the
B these songs are all great a lot of the
folk history of these songs is quite
dubious notice she doesn't really cite
her sources here because I suspect she
cannot but but let's go even further she
says that some of these songs were
related to the minstral tradition the
minstral tradition included a lot of
black people Billy kersands was one of
the most famous minstral performers and
writers in American history did
blackface performances even though he's
a black guy created the anima character
which other white liberals canceled do
we we need to cancel his career because
some white lib in the year 2023 doesn't
like it no these are good songs and they
need to keep their trap shut keep your
damn mouth shut
okay la la la la la
[Music]
la